[Aplausos]
a nadie le debe importar salvar el
planeta
así es a nadie
le debe importar
y salvar el planeta
aún recuerdo cuando escuché esta frase
por primera vez
salvo el planeta cuida el medio ambiente
he de haber tenido
67 años que llovió
seguramente a ti te ha pasado lo mismo a
lo largo de tu vida has escuchado tantas
veces esto salva el planeta
cuida el medio ambiente y lo escuchas
tanto que de alguna forma se vuelve
monótono
es algo que simplemente sabes que está
ahí
simplemente sabes que existe
estás consciente que hay un problema de
que de salvar el planeta pero se ha
vuelto tan recurrente
que simplemente está
y pocas personas son conscientes
de que día con día
el planeta se va calentando
o pocos son conscientes
de que día a día
más toneladas de co2 son lanzadas hacia
el medio ambiente
cuando queremos hablar de estos temas
tenemos que hablar de sustentabilidad
y podemos buscarlo en todas partes y
escucharemos mil y un definiciones pero
en realidad lo que significa
sustentabilidad es equilibrio
se trata de tener un equilibrio todo en
la vida necesita tener equilibrio
todo en la vida necesita tener un orden
y a pesar de que nosotros lo hemos
escuchado a lo largo de nuestra vida del
planeta cuida el medio ambiente
yo me sigo encontrar los datos como
estos
cada segundo se tala el equivalente a un
campo de fútbol americano
cada segundo
nos estamos acabando los bosques
pensando como si fueran infinitos
la tierra
alcanzado la temperatura máxima en los
últimos 115 mil años
cada segundo
se arrojan al mar 200 toneladas de
plástico
para el año 2050 vamos a tener más
plástico que animales
y porque si sabemos por qué si nos han
dicho todo el tiempo
que debemos salvar el planeta
porque realmente no lo hemos logrado
porque tenemos un sistema económico
y en términos muy muy muy generales
puede explicar lo que es el sistema
económico
tienes países que tienen que generar
riqueza riqueza para poder tener
infraestructura riqueza para poder hacer
hospitales
riqueza para poder tener programas
sociales y cómo es esto pues explotar
sus recursos naturales
y está bien estoy de acuerdo con el
intercambio el único factor que ellos no
tomaron en cuenta cuando hicieron el
sistema económico es el tiempo
si tú tal es un árbol hoy
cuánto tiempo tarda en crecer
yo tardó cinco minutos en hacer una
cubeta de plástico
5 minutos
y tardo un millón de años en que se
degrade
y digo yo no soy ningún científico pero
siento que en 35 minutos y un millón de
años si existe como que alguna
diferencia
y es una diferencia pues que será
bastante significativa
y que genera este desequilibrio que
genera el que nosotros tenemos sobre
explotando nuestros recursos
huracanes
tsunamis
inundaciones
el deshielo de los polos
incendios forestales
todas estas catástrofes
se van a volver algo recurrente en
nuestras vidas si de por sí ya es algo
que vemos muy seguido si no tenemos la
conciencia suficiente lo que va a pasar
es que lo vamos a seguir viendo y cada
vez más y cada vez más y cada vez más
y es por eso que yo digo que a nadie le
debe importar salvar el planeta
porque claramente
se ve que lo que el planeta quiere al
tener ese desequilibrio
lo que quieres matarte
lo que quiere es que no tú no estés aquí
el culpable y seamos realistas
de toda esta contaminación somos
nosotros
y los que debemos asumir esa
responsabilidad somos nosotros
por eso digo
porque yo me enfocaría
es salvar el planeta
cuando sabemos que el planeta para que
esté bien y esté saludable es que tú no
estés aquí
y es por eso que yo digo y la idea que
vengo exponer hoy usted
que el enfoque debe cambiar lo que le
estamos enseñando a los niños de salve
el planeta es un enfoque malo
no debe de ir por ahí
el enfoque que yo digo es salvar la raza
humana
salva a los tuyos
durante años nos han dicho lo mismo
steve cuida este árbol
steve cuida este árbol tiene oxígeno te
da sombra
steve quid está este árbol
y que lo que hace estilo y lo que hace
la sociedad
balotta la y se hace una silla
si te están diciendo que esto lo que te
está dando vida porque lo destruyes
entonces el enfoque va a cambiar y si yo
les digo
cuida tu hijo
salva a tu hijo
y el enfoque cambia ahí es donde yo ya
realmente le empiezo a poner la
importancia que debe tener
hay muchas veces que
yo cuando digo que realmente hay que
enfocarnos
en salvar a la raza humana
pues me refutan porque si el planeta es
donde vivimos
pues claro pero tienes que generar una
conciencia
debe de generar una conciencia ecológica
que esté realmente enterado de lo que
está pasando porque lo vemos pasar lo
vemos día a día y como les decía se
vuelve algo monótono
qué es lo que debes de hacer debes tomar
acción
y me dicen pero es que estiba y tratados
está el tratado de parís
el tratado de río claro
pero hoy por hoy
el desarrollo sostenible global es un
fracaso
porque a pesar de que los líderes de a
pesar de que la gente
realmente toma las decisiones por
nosotros
está firmando papeles
seguimos viendo que están talando
seguimos viendo todo el cambio y
realmente no vemos algo que se vea
consistente entonces el pensar de forma
global
está fracasando
sin embargo el desarrollo sostenible
local es una realidad
y quiero que hoy tú te imagines que
tienes en tus manos
el poder de generar un cambio
el poder de hacer pequeñas acciones que
inevitablemente van a generar una
diferencia
quiero que sepas y que tú te imagines
que cada acción que hagas para cuidar el
planeta es porque quieres que tus hijos
estén ahí bien
es porque estás diciendo a las futuras
generaciones les estás agradeciendo
pequeñas acciones
generan una gran diferencia
y aquí el mayor reto de latinoamérica
es poder trabajar en equipo yo sé que
este es un problema que tenemos pues si
quieren de cultura o no sé
que no nos cuesta un trabajo ponernos de
acuerdo
nos cuesta bastante poder trabajar en
equipo
han escuchado mil historias de lo del
cangrejo etcétera
pero siempre queremos ver al de al lado
más tornado que nosotros pero aquí ya no
es algo que sea una competencia aquí ya
no se trata de que sea mejor alguien
etcétera aquí ya es algo para nuestra
propia existencia es algo que va a
repercutir en los nuestros
debemos aceptar que somos uno más con el
ambiente
debemos de quitarnos ese egoísmo
implícito que tenemos
y realmente tomar la importancia de las
cosas que son
debemos de respetar las demás especies
que viven con nosotros deja de pensar
que vales más que el de al lado porque
no es así todos compartimos un lugar
y todos debemos trabajar para salvar
este lugar
el primer paso es quitemos nuestra
adicción que tenemos por el petróleo esa
adicción a quemar quemar quemar quemar
si bien el que más nos ha hecho la
sociedad que somos hoy actualmente que
ha permitido que hay avances
tecnológicos impresionantes sí claro
sin embargo hay que tener un cambio
paulatino para dejar
esa adicción al petróleo
uno de los uno de estos pasos es generar
su propia electricidad
de repente yo convivo con gente que me
dice deje la luz de fuera aprendida toda
la noche
para que si tú estás en tu casa
para que piensen que si estoy no se
metan
o de repente gente que dice
entonces quiero gramos con la tele
prendida nomás para que haga ruido
y así hay bastantes casos
que tú realmente piensas oye es que no
tienes conciencia
se ha vuelto para nosotros
natural el llegar y prender la luz de
nuestra casa
que hemos perdido la noción de lo que
hay atrás
se ha vuelto tan natural
el poder llegar prender tu tele poner
netflix
y realmente ya no tenemos la conciencia
de que atrás están quemando combustibles
fósiles o de que atrás le están dando en
toda la torre del planeta
también uno de los cambios que ellos
propongo
utiliza un carro eléctrico
si bien entiendo que hoy por hoy no son
los más baratos y que son los pocos
tienen acceso a él pues está bien no
compres un carro eléctrico nada más no
uses tu carro para la tienda que está en
la esquina
ten conciencia de lo que está pasando
no uses tanto plástico y hoy por hoy
quiero comentarles algo que estoy muy
orgulloso de trabajar una empresa que
realmente
es muy consciente ecológicamente
y que estoy muy orgulloso de mi equipo
porque se hicieron políticas como 0 p 0
papel
me gusta trabajar con gente que
realmente tiene esa conciencia de que si
estamos haciendo un daño
y por eso quiero dejarlos con esta frase
que dice
sólo después de que el último árbol se
ha cortado solo después de que el último
río se ha envenenado solo después de que
el último pez se ha apresado solo
entonces sabrás que el dinero no se
puede comer
hoy por hoy tienes que ser un cambio
y un cambio local empieza por ti empieza
por inspirar al de al lado porque es muy
fácil quejarse y decir tú escribes si no
no lo hace pero empieza por hacerlo tú
empieza por generarle conciencia a tus
hijos empieza por generar en general de
conciencia con los que vienen atrás de
ti
gracias
[Aplausos]